ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
creative commons license.
Your support will help MIT Open
Courseware continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So you've
been learning
about statistical mechanics.
The microscopic underpinnings
of thermodynamics.
And last time we ended up
working with the canonical
partition function and showing
that once you have the
canonical position function,
you have basically every
thermodynamic quantity that
you've learned how to
calculate this far
in the course.
But before I start, on the
lecture notes 25, there were a
couple typos in there that
actually didn't make any
difference to the final
result because they
cancel each other out.
But it's been corrected
on the web version.
And near the bottom of the page
-- because we're going to
be mostly using these
notes today.
Near the bottom of the page,
where it says A is equal to u
minus TS is equal to u.
That should be a plus
here. dA/dT, volume.
And then further down
the next line, blah
blah blah blah blah.
Minus u over T squared.
And this should be
a minus here.
One over T. dA/dT,
V. And et cetera.
So luckily these two typos
cancel each other out the
result is correct.
But there it is.
OK.
So last time, then, you saw
how from the canonical
partition function, you could
get something like the energy.
You wrote down an equation.
The energy is equal to k,
T squared, d log Q / dT.
Under constant volume.
And number of particles.
And then you notice that the
important variables are the
volume, the number of
particles, and the
temperature.
And we know that every
thermodynamic quantity has a
set of natural variables.
For the Gibbs free energy it
was the pressure and the
temperature, the number
of particles.
And for the volume of the number
of particles and the
temperature, we know that that's
the Helmholtz energy.
So the natural variable that
we would associate -- the
natural thermodynamic variable
we would associate with that
set of constraints is the
Helmholtz free energy.
So it becomes interesting, then,
to figure out, how can
we write the Helmholtz free
energy in terms of the
canonical partition function?
They seem to have the same
set of natural variables.
And that's what you started
doing and what we'll do today.
And that's where the
typo comes in.
So let's write what we know
about the Helmholtz free
energy in terms of
the energy u.
I already wrote it up
there. u minus TS.
That's the definition of the
Helmholtz free energy.
And from the fact that dA is
equal to minus p dV, minus S
dT, plus mu dN.
We can read out what S, here,
is in terms of the Helmholtz
free energy.
S is just dA/dT, constant V and
N. So we can plug that in
here. u minus T dA, with a
minus sign there, so that
becomes a plus.
And hence the typo. dT,
constant V, and N. OK.
So now we have an equation
that relates u and the
partition function.
We want an equation
that relates A and
the partition function.
If we rearrange this slightly,
we can get that u, then, is
equal to A minus T, dA/dT,
constant V and N. So the
question that we could ask
ourselves is -- is there a
function of A that kind
of looks like that?
And I know the answer, so I'm
going to give it to you.
A function of A that looks
like the sum of A minus
something times the derivative,
with respect to
that something.
We should try to look at
something like the derivative
d(A/T)/dT, constant V and
N. So if you take that
derivative, you end up with
one over T, dA/dT, minus A
over T squared.
But if you look at this result,
here, and you multiply
by T squared, there's the A, and
there's the T times dA/dT.
There's the A that -- we just
have the sign wrong.
So we have -- multiply this
by minus T squared.
Minus T squared, times
minus T squared.
And you have the same
thing as here.
So that tells us then, that u
can be written as minus T
squared, d(A/T)/dT,
constant volume.
It's a nice way to relate
those two energies.
And we have an expression
for u in terms of
the canonical function.
And we can then replace
it in here.
And that gets us, then, that
minus T squared, d(A/T)/dT,
constant number and volume
is equal to u.
And u, we saw, was equal to
k T squared d log Q / dT.
V and N fixed.
And then we can start --
The t squareds disappear here.
And then we have d/dT on
this side and d/dT.
Let's just take the integral.
You take the integral of both
sides, and that gets us that
then A over T is equal to k,
log Q, plus the constant of
integration.
And we can take that constant
of integration to
be whatever we want.
Energy is all relative to
some reference point.
We can take it to be zero.
A is equal to k T log Q.
That's a pretty neat result.
There's the microscopic
underpinning of things.
Where we know about atoms, and
energies, and states, and even
quantum mechanics,
and all sorts of
things goes into here.
All the microscopic information
goes in here.
And there's a thermodynamic
variable that only cares about
the macroscopic state
of matter.
It doesn't care that there
are atoms there.
It just cares that you know the
pressure, the volume, the
temperature, or any
couple variables.
And you can get a direct
equality without any
derivatives or anything.
Between the macroscopic
and the microscopic.
So this is really pretty
remarkable.
And once you have A, you
have everything.
Just like before, we said once
you have G, that Gibbs free
energy, when we were talking
about things that depend on
pressure and temperature.
You have everything.
It's the same thing here.
We've got A, we've got u.
We have everything.
We can calculate every
single thermodynamic
variable from then on.
For instance, if we want to have
the entropy, S is equal
to minus A over T, minus u over
T. Where did I get that?
I got that from way up here.
A is equal to u minus TS.
I solved for S in terms
of A and u.
I've got expressions in
terms of the canonical
function for A and u.
Plug that in there.
Get k log Q, plus k T, d log
Q / dT, constant number and
volume. et cetera.
You can get the pressure.
You can get the pressure from
the fact that the pressure up
here is a derivative of A
with respect to volume.
So you take the derivative of A
with respect to volume here.
You get the pressure.
If you want the chemical
potential.
The chemical potential from the
fundamental equation up
here is the derivative
of A with respect to
the number of particles.
You take the derivative of A
with respect to the number of
particles, you get the chemical
potential in terms of
the canonical partition
function.
So you've got everything.
You've got u.
You've got A. You've got p.
You've got S. You've got H.
You've got G. Name your
valuable, you've got it.
You want the heat capacity?
It can get you the heat capacity
in terms of the
partition function.
Any questions?
Alright so let's go on.
Let's look a little bit closer
at the entropy, in terms of
the microscopic theory here.
So let's start with S is A minus
u over T. And let's see
how far we can go.
Alright.
Let's write it in terms of --
let's write A and u in terms
of things that we know.
And let me just go to the end
to tell you where I'm going,
and why I'm going
to make certain
changes in my math here.
So what we're going to get at
the end is that S is this very
nice quantity, which is
minus k, pi log pi.
Where the p's are the microstate
probabilities.
The probability that your state
is in a particular --
yes?
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: S is u minus A. Yes.
u minus A. Thank you.
I should read my notes.
OK.
So we're going to equate
S here in terms of the
probabilities of microstates.
And that's going to be --
remember how we talked about S
is related to concepts
of randomness,
or order, or disorder.
So the number of possible
microstates is related to the
number of amount of disorder
that you might have.
If you have a pure crystal,
and every atom is in its
place, then the number of
microstates at zero degree
Kelvin is one.
So the probability of being
in that microstate is one.
And the probability of
being in every other
microstate is zero.
Alright, so there's a
relationship that we're going
to have here, which is going
to be interesting.
Let's derive it.
That means that we're going to
want to have this somehow pop
out of the equation.
We're going to want to have this
pop out of the equation.
If you remember, pi is the --
pi is e to the minus the Ei
over kT, divided by the
partition function Q. So
somehow we are going to have
to get this to come out.
We're going to have to have
these e to the minus Ei over
kT's come out.
OK.
So let's try to get them
to come out right away.
We know u.
A way to write u is the
average energy.
Which means let's take
one over kT out here.
And there's a -- let's
divided by k here.
Let's get the k here. kT here.
We're going to want to have
a k come out here.
There's the k here.
So that's one way of getting
it to come out.
And then the u is going to be
the average energy. e to the
minus Ei, minus kT.
That's just writing the
average energy.
So the energy times the
probability of having that
energy divided by the
normalization.
Plus, well, A is just log Q.
A over kT is just log Q. So
we've managed to extract
this guy out here.
OK.
Now, this sum, here,
this is sum over i.
I'd really like to have this
sum come all the way out.
So I've got to find
a way to do that.
And it would be nice if I
could find a sum here.
Maybe if I multiply by one.
If I write one in a funny way.
Get a log here.
You know, if I've got a couple
logs here, maybe I can combine
them to get a ratio.
So let's rewrite this Ei
in a funny way, here.
Ei is --
I'm just rewriting it,
but in a strange way.
Log e to the minus Ei over kT.
So if I take the log of e to
the minus the Ei over kT.
I get minus Ei over kT.
The kT's disappear.
So I just get Ei
is equal to Ei.
I'm just writing something
that's pretty obvious here.
And then we're going to
take that expression,
and put it in here.
So now I'm going to be able to
write S over k is minus --
So the kT here cancels
out this kT here.
Sum over i. e to the
minus Ei over kT.
Over Q. That's that
term right here.
And then I have the Ei,
which is log e to the
minus Ei over kT.
This whole thing is in this
parenthesis here.
And then I have the plus log
Q. Plus log Q. OK.
So I have this nice thing here.
e to the minus Ei over
kT divided by Q. Well that's
looking an awful lot
like this pi here.
Which is what I'm trying
to get out.
I'm trying to get these
pi's coming out.
So that's a nice thing
to have here.
Now if I could only have a pi
coming out here, somehow, that
would be great too.
And if I also got a sum here,
that's a sum over i I could
sort of combine everything
together.
So I'm going to write
one in a funny way.
One is equal to the sum
of all probabilities.
That's obvious.
And I'm going to write this
pi here in a form
that looks like this.
Sum over all i, e to the minus
Ei over kT, divided by Q. Just
writing one.
The sum of all probability
is equal to one.
And I'm going to take this one,
here, and I'm going to
put it right in here.
Now log Q doesn't care on i,
so it's just a number.
So that allows me
to rewrite --
S over k is minus the sum over
i. e to the minus Ei over kT,
divided by the partition
function.
Times the log of e to the
minus Ei over kT.
Plus sum over i, e to the minus
Ei over kT over Q. Times
log
Q. OK good.
I'm going to take these
summations.
Now everything is over
the sum of Ei.
This is great.
And there's this factor here.
E to the minus Ei over
kT divided by
the partition function.
That appears in both.
I can factor that out. and.
Then I have these two logs.
Log of this and log of that.
That I can also combine
together.
This is the log of this.
And then there's a minus sign.
So if I take the -- it's going
to be the log of this minus
the log of that,.
It's going to end
up with a ratio.
S over k is equal to minus Ei.
Taking the summation out. e to
the minus Ei over kT, over Q.
That's this term.
That term.
And then I have the logs.
Log of e to the minus
Ei over kT.
This is a minus sign.
This is a plus sign.
That means I divide here
by Q. This is great.
Look.
This e to the minus Ei over kT
over Q. e to the minus Ei over
kT over Q. What is that?
That's just pi.
This is pi.
That's the probability
of microstate i.
And this is equal to minus
sum over i, pi log pi.
There's the k, here.
S is equal to minus k, log
sum over i, pi, log pi.
Another great result.
Now if you system is isolated.
If you have an isolated
system, that means
that the energy --
You've got your boundary.
The boundary doesn't let
energy go in and out.
Doesn't let the number of
particles go in and out.
Every single microstate is going
to have the same energy.
If this system is isolated.
The only thing you're going
to change is the
positions of the particles.
Or their vibrational energy.
Or something.
But let's just stick
with translation.
You're just going to change
the positions.
You're not going to
change the energy.
So, if the system is isolated,
then the degeneracy of your
energy is just a number of ways
that you can flip the
positions around.
Indistinguishable ways.
So the probability is just one
over the number of possible
ways of switching positions
around for your particles.
So for an isolated system,
all microstates
have the same energy.
We can set that equal to zero
as our reference point.
And the probability of being in
any one microstate is just
one over the number
of possible ways
of rearranging things.
So the probability of been in
any one microstate is one over
the number of my microstates.
They all have the same energy.
Where this is the degeneracy.
So now when you plug that
in here, S is minus k.
Sum over all microstates from
one to blah, one over blah,
log of blah.
This is a number.
It can come out.
The sum of one to omega.
Of one over omega.
Is omega times omega.
It's one.
The one over omega -- the log of
one over omega is minus the
log of omega.
The negative signs cancel out.
k log capital omega.
For an isolated system.
You've seen this before,
probably.
This is called the Boltzmann
equation.
And that is what is
on his tombstone.
If you go to - I think it's
in Germany somewhere.
Is it in Germany?
Do you guys know?
STUDENT: Austria.
PROFESSOR: Austria, thank you.
I knew it was that part
of the world.
If you go to Austria, to some
famous cemetery, and go look
for the tombstone that says
S is equal to log omega.
That's where Boltzmann
is buried.
OK.
So this picture of
-- yes question?
STUDENT: Can you repeat the
argument for making that one
over omega go away?
PROFESSOR: Making the one
over omega go away here?
Because you're taking the sum
of all states from one, i
equals one to omega.
So it's one over our omega plus
one over omega plus one
over omega plus --
omega times.
And this is just a number.
So it comes out.
It's not in the sum.
So the sum, here, is
all by itself.
Any other questions?
OK.
That's why we talk about
entropy as being this
fundamental property that tells
you about the number of
available states.
That's what it is.
You've got this connection now
between this variable, which
is sort of hard to really
intuitively understand, when
you're talking about
thermodynamics.
And this is much easier to
understand here, in terms of
the available ways of
distributing your energy, or
your particles, in
this case here.
In different bins.
OK any questions?
So the next topic is we're going
to work a little bit
with the partition functions.
And see how when you have
systems that have multiple
degrees of freedom, where each
degree of freedom has a
different kind of energy.
Let's say translation,
rotation, vibration.
Then you can have a partition
function for each of these
degrees of freedom.
And whereas the energies of the
degrees of freedom add up,
the partition functions
get multiplied.
So it's the separation of the
partition functions into
subsystem partition functions.
So so far, we've written for
translation partition function.
That the system partition
function is the molecular
partition function
to the Nth power.
If you have distinguishable
particles.
And you have to divide
by N factorial.
If you can swap particles
without knowing the
difference.
This is the number of ways of
swapping N particles with each
other, so it's indistinguishable
particles.
OK.
So now let's say that --
Let's just make sure that --
Let's say that your energy
of your system -- yes?
STUDENT: It says that when
system's not isolated,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Where does
it say that?
In the notes?
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Let me see
the notes here.
What does it say?
So that sentence has to
do with this guy here.
Basically it says that if
you've got a huge number
particles, the average energy
is a given number.
And the fluctuations around that
average are very small.
And so, the system behaves
as if it's isolated.
So when you have a system which
is not isolated, then
energy can come in and
out of the system.
So in principle, over time,
you could have huge energy
fluctuations.
As energy comes out,
or energy comes in.
And if you have a countable
number of molecules in your
system, then if one molecule
suddenly captures a lot of
energy, then the whole system
energy will go up a lot.
But if you have ten to the
24th molecules, if one
molecule suddenly gains a lot
of energy, the system energy
doesn't care.
So small fluctuations -- or big
fluctuations in the small
number of molecules doesn't
make any difference to the
total energy.
And so you can still
use this then.
It's good enough.
STUDENT: So how long is that
good enough [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well if it's
accountable, a handful of
things, and it's not valid.
If it's ten to the 24th and it's
valid, and somewhere in
between it breaks down.
Then I don't know what
the answer is.
But usually if you have a
thermodynamic system, then
it's big enough.
That's what thermodynamics
is about.
Where you don't really care
that you have atoms there.
You don't even know you
have atoms there.
So it's big enough.
Good question.
Alright, so now let's take our
microstate energy here.
And our microstate energy is the
sum of all the molecular
energies Ei.
So it's the sum of all
energies E sub,
over all the atoms.
And each one of these energies,
if it's a molecular
energies, can be indexed by a
quantum number of some sort.
So it would be the sum
over all energies.
So quantum number for particle
one, n1 is some sort of
quantum number. n2 is some sort
of quantum number. n3 is
some sort of quantum number.
And then you have all
the molecules.
En1 plus En2 plus
En3, et cetera.
So this is the energy from
molecule one, energy from
molecule two, energy from
molecule three, energy from
molecule four.
And that little n tells you
which energy state that
molecule is.
And the sum of all
these energies is
your microstate energy.
As long as you can write this
this way, then you're allowed
to write this this way.
So that basically means that
they're not interacting with
each other.
They're independent
from each other.
In this case here.
So now if I write Q in terms
of the sum over all
microstates Ei. e to the
minus Ei over kT.
I'm going to replace this Ei
here with the sum over all
these energies here.
And so the sum over all
microstates, then, becomes the
sum over all possible
combinations of quantum
numbers. n1, n2, n3,
n4, et cetera.
All the possible
ways of getting
molecule one in some state.
All the possible ways of getting
molecule two in some
quantum number state.
And then e to the minus -- and
instead of capital Ei, I'm
going to write the molecular
energies.
En1, plus En2, plus epsilon
n3 plus et cetera.
And then divide by kT.
Basically I'm going to prove
that this is a fine statement
to make, as long as you can
write the energy as a sum of
component energies.
OK so now this term here, e to
the minus En1, only cares
about this sum here.
En2, that's molecule number
two, only cares
about this sum here.
Molecule number three only cares
about the sum over all
possible quantum numbers
connected to
molecule number three.
So I can factor out all these
sums into a factor of sums.
Is equal to the sum over quantum
number n1. e to the
minus epsilon of n1,
divided by kT.
Times n2 e to the minus epsilon
n2 over kT, times n3 e
to the minus epsilon n3 divided
by kT, et cetera.
And now each one of these is
basically the molecular
partition function.
These are all the possible
energies of that molecule.
And the sum over all possible
energies times e to the minus
E over kT is the partition
function for the molecule.
So we have q for molecule one
times q for molecule two.
And they're all the same.
There are N of them.
Plus q to the N. So just, in a
way, clarified that the reason
why we're able to write this
system partition function, in
terms of the molecular partition
functions, with N of
them, to the Nth power, is
because we were able to
separate out the energy here.
In terms of the independent
molecular energies.
Where this is saying the
molecules don't interact with
each other.
And are independent
from each other.
And then the one over N
factorial comes in, so that
you don't over count, for
translation, the positions.
They're indistinguishable.
OK.
So now we can have --
Actually we're not --
This basic concept of the
partition function multiplying
each other, if the energies add,
is not limited to going
from the molecular partition
functions to the system
partition function.
You can also look
at the molecular
partition function itself.
And if the energy, the molecular
energy, can be
written in terms of a sum of
energies of different degrees
of freedom, for instance, the
energy of a molecule could be
the energy of the vibration,
plus the energy of the
translation, plus the energy
of the rotation, plus the
energy of the magnetic field,
plus the energy of the
electric field. et cetera.
You have many energies that can
add up with each other to
create the molecular energy.
And what we're going to be able
to write, then, is that
this molecular partition
function itself can be written
in terms of a product of
partition functions for the
sub parts of the molecular
energy.
So let me clarify
that statement.
So if I can write my molecular
energy, epsilon, is equal to a
translational energy, plus a
vibrational energy, plus a
rotational energy, plus every
other little energies that you
can think of that are
independent of each other.
Then using the same argument we
used to show that Q is the
multiplication of these
molecular partition function,
we can write that the molecular
partition function,
little q, is just the
multiplication of the degree
of freedom partition
functions --
molecular partition functions.
The translational partition
function times the vibrational
partition function, times
the rotational partition
function, et cetera.
If the energies add, then the
partition functions multiply
each other.
And that's going to be powerful
because when we look
at something like a polymer or
DNA or protein or something,
in solution.
And we're going to be looking at
the configurations possible
for that polymer or that
biopolymer, then we'll know
that the energy of that polymer
in solution is going
to be -- we'll be able to
approximate it as the energy
of the configuration
for that polymer.
The different ways that
you can fold the
protein, for instance.
Plus everything else.
The energy of everything else.
OK.
So if the configurational energy
can be separated from
the sum of all vibration
energies of all the bonds in
that polymer.
The way that polymer
interacts with --
The way that the solution itself
interacts with itself.
Then if we can do this and we
can do this approximation most
of the time, then we'll be able
to take the partition
function for the polymer,
and write it as the
configurational partition
function times the partition
function for everything else.
And we'll find that this part
here will tend to factor out.
We won't have to
worry about it.
And that this will carry all the
important information that
we'll need to know to see about
changes in the system.
Changes in Gibbs free
energy, changes in
the chemical potential.
Everything will be related to
this partition function.
This subsystem.
And because of the fact that you
can factor them out, then
this thing will end
up dropping out.
And this will become the
important factor.
OK.
Let's do a quick example.
So this is the example
of having a
very very, short polymer.
Containing three monomers.
Which can be in two
configurations.
And the energies are the same
for these two configurations.
So the configurational partition
function, which you
would generally write as the sum
of e to the minus Ei for
that configuration, divided
by kT, plus e to the --
So we would usually write it as
e to the minus epsilon one
over kT, plus e to the
minus epsilon two
over kT, plus et cetera.
They're all the same energy.
And there are two
configurations.
The degeneracy is two.
So you can write this as
the degeneracy of the
configuration, times the energy
of the configuration.
And you can set your energy
reference to be zero.
You can choose whatever
you want it to be.
And zero is a good number.
So that e to the zero
is equal to one.
So that configuration partition
function is just the
degeneracy, which is equal to
two, in this case here.
So now let's calculate the
molecular and canonical
partition functions for
an ideal gas of
these molecules here.
And it's usually interesting
to use a
lattice model as a guide.
And so in this lattice model
here, you would divide space
up into little cells.
Pieces in two dimensions, but
in reality it would be three
dimensions.
And then you place your
molecules in lattice sites.
Something like this.
And then you end up counting
the number of ways of
arranging the molecules
on the lattice.
And let's say that we have
N molecules that
are in the gas phase.
And the molecular volume, i.e.
the size of the lattice site
is v. That's the molecular
volume.
And N times v is the
total volume.
That's the total volume occupied
by the particles.
The total volume is the number
of lattice sites.
V is the total volume.
And we're going to assume that
all particles, all molecules
have the same translation
energy.
It's an adequate
approximation.
We're going to set that
equal to zero.
So all molecules at any position
here has the same E
translation.
And we're going to set
that equal to zero.
So the translational
partition function.
The molecular transitional
partition function is --
Well there's only one energy.
It's zero.
So we only care about the
degeneracy of that molecule.
That molecule could be in here,
or it could be here, it
could be here, it could
be here, it could
be anywhere, right?
The number of ways of putting
that molecule on the lattice
is the number of lattice
sites available.
Which is basically the
molecular volume.
Which is the total
volume divided by
the molecular volume.
The total volume is -- right.
So the total volume is the
number of lattice sites times
the volume of each
lattice site.
So the total volume divided by
the small volume is the total
number of lattice sites.
And the number of choices of
putting that one molecule is
anywhere on the lattice.
That's your degeneracy.
So now if I look at the total
molecular partition function,
it's going to be the
multiplication of the
configurational partition
function and the translational
partition function.
At each site, the molecule could
have two configurations.
So q, for the molecule, that's
q translational.
I'm going to ignore
all vibrations,
rotation, et cetera.
I'm going to assume that there
are two degrees of freedom.
Translational one, which is
basically the positional one.
And then the configurational
one, which is
internal to the molecule.
So this one is V over v.
That's the degeneracy.
Capital V over little v. The
degeneracy of placing the
molecule on the lattice.
And the configuration is
the degeneracy of how
the molecule folds.
Yes.
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The notes
are wrong.
So usually capital V is large
and little v is small.
So in the notes, if we
have it in reverse,
we should fix that.
This is lecture 25, right?
So we have q.
No the notes seem to be right.
Total volume is capital V,
molecular volume is little v.
Where is it that wrong
in the notes?
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh look at that.
My notes are different
than yours.
My notes are right.
OK well it's obviously
right on the web.
Because this is the
latest version.
Alright so flip those big
V's and little v's then.
Huh.
I thought they were from
the same pile.
OK.
So this is your molecular
partition function.
And then when you look at the
system, the system partition
function can also be separated
into a translation and the
configuration for the system.
We know what you need to do
is take all the molecular
partition functions, the
transitional ones, and -- to
the N factor.
The number of particles.
But now you have degeneracy.
You've over counted.
So you need to divide
this N factorial.
You also have the system
partition function for the
configurations.
And that's q configuration to
the N. Except here we don't
need to divide by one over N
factorial, because we're not
over counting here.
The over counting only happens
when you're placing identical
particles in a lattice, and
you can swap them without
making a difference.
Here we talking about
configurations.
When we're talking about
configurations, we're not
talking about placing the
identical particles in
different spots.
We're just looking at these
two configurations here.
And then the next particle
is two configurations.
The next particle is
two configurations.
So this is really important.
That this N over factorial
only comes into play when
you're talking about the
translational degree of freedom.
Not the other degrees
of freedom.
And now the total system
partition function is the
multiplication of these two.
It ends up being capital V over
v, to the N power, over N
factorial, times
two to the N. OK.
In general you could extend
this analysis to include
vibrations, rotations, energy
in a magnetical field,
electric field, et cetera.
Any questions?
Alright the next thing that
you're going to do then is to
use this concept, as a sort of
example, as a way to begin to
calculate things that you've
already calculated before.
For instance, if you look at an
expansion of an ideal gas,
can we now calculate
the entropy change.
Not based on thermodynamics,
but based on
the statistical mechanics.
On the microscopic description
that we've just gone through.
And it turns out that
that's what happens.
That you can do that.
You get the same answer.
Thank god you get
the same answer.
Otherwise we'd be
in big trouble.
So I'm just going to set up the
problem, because I won't
have time to do it.
And then you can do it next
time, when Keith comes back.
So the problem is going to be
the usual problem of having a
volume V1 of a gas on one side,
and a vaccuum expanding
to volume V2, gas.
And asking what is the
entropy change.
And you know that from thermo,
that delta S in this case here
is nR log V2 over V1, when the
temperature is constant.
That's going to be our answer.
It has to be our answer.
But this time, instead of
knowing the answer, we're
going to calculate it
from microscopics.
So what you do is you start out
with your initial state.
You ask what is -- you write
down the molecular volume V.
The total volume here is V1.
You assume that all molecules
have the same
translational energy.
You set that equal to zero.
The system translational energy
is equal to zero.
And so the entropy for this gas
here is just the number of
ways of placing the molecule
in the lattice.
This model that we have of space
being separated into
little cells.
And so S is k log omega, where
omega is the number of ways of
placing the molecules
in the lattice.
Which is basically k log V,
over v. Where this is the
number of lattice sites.
OK.
And what you're going to
do next time, then,
is start from here.
Calculate what it is before.
Calculate what it is after, and
turn the crank, and get to
the right answer.
Then you're going to do the
same thing for liquids.
And that'll be it for this
simple statistical mechanics.